>>> ANOTHER TEST TODAY OF DONALD
TRUMP'S HOLD ON GOP VOTERS
IT IS PRIMARY DAY IN TWO STATES.
LET'S START IN ALASKA.
LISA MURKOWSKI, THE ONLY
REPUBLICAN SENATOR UP FOR
RE-ELECTION THIS YEAR WHO VOTED
TO CONVICT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AFTER HIS SECOND IMPEACHMENT,
FACES TRUMP-BACKED CHALLENGER
KELLY TSHIBAKA.
>> SARAH PALIN IS HOPING FOR A
POLITICAL COMEBACK IN HER BID
FOR THE STATE'S LONE U.S. HOUSE
SEAT.
AND IN WYOMING, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ CHENEY, WHO
VOTED TO IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP
AND IS CRISIS CHAIR OF THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE IS IN A
TOUGH BATTLE AGAINST
TRUMP-ENDORSED CHALLENGER
HARRIET HAGEMAN.
LET'S BRING IN JEFF ZELENY.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM VOTERS
THERE?
>> Reporter: WE ARE HEARING THAT
CONGRESSMAN LIZ CHENEY VOTED A
SHORT TIME AGO AT THE COUNTY
LIBRARY IN JACKSON, CHOOSING NOT
TO CAST HER BALLOT HERE AT HER
NEIGHBORHOOD POLLING LOCATION
WHERE A LOT OF RESIDENTS AND A
LOT OF MEDIA, FRANKLY, WERE
EXPECTING THAT SHE WOULD, SO
CLEARLY TRYING TO AVOID THAT
TRADITIONAL ELECTION DAY PHOTO
OPPORTUNITY, SAVING HER ONLY
PUBLIC APPEARANCE FOR HER EVENT
THIS EVENING.
BUT TALKING TO SO MANY VOTERS
HERE, SUPPORTERS OF LIZ CHENEY
KNOW THIS IS AN UPHILL BATTLE.
SHE KNOWS THIS IS AN UPHILL
BATTLE.
WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
DEMOCRATS AND INDEPENDENTS
CROSSING OVER TO SUPPORT HER.
WE'VE ALSO MET SEVERAL
REPUBLICAN VOTERS WHO SAY THEY
PROUDLY STAND BEHIND HER,
INCLUDING JOHN GRANT, WHO CAST
HIS BALLOT HERE TODAY.
>> CERTAINLY IS A TOUGH RACE FOR
LIZ.
I'VE BEEN A SUPPORTER OF HER FOR
QUITE SOME TIME, AND I WISH HER
THE BEST.
I THINK SHE DOES A GOOD JOB.
I THINK SHE WORKS HARD AT WHAT
SHE DOES.
I THINK SHE STOOD UP FOR WHAT
SHE BELIEVES IN.
I MEAN, IT TOOK A LOT OF COURAGE
TO STAND UP AND STEP AGAINST THE
REPUBLICAN -- DONALD TRUMP AND
THE REPUBLICANS IN GENERAL.
>> Reporter: BUT CLEARLY, THAT
IS A REPUBLICAN WHO SAID HE'S
FRANKLY FED UP WITH DONALD TRUMP
AND WANTS THE PARTY TO MOVE ON.
THAT SIMPLY HAS NOT HAPPENED.
A LONG STRING OF PRIMARIES
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER HAS MADE
ONE THING CLEAR.
THIS IS STILL DONALD TRUMP'S
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AND THERE'S NO CONTEST IN THE
COUNTRY THROUGHOUT THE YEAR THAT
HAS BEEN MORE IMPORTANT TO HIM
THAN WINNING THAN HERE IN
WYOMING.
HE'S ENDORSED HARRIET HAGEMAN, A
LONG-TIME LAWYER HERE IN
WYOMING, WHO CERTAINLY HAS A
COMMANDING LEAD GOING INTO
ELECTION DAY AGAINST LIZ CHENEY,
SO WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS FOR
THE REMAINING HOURS OF VOTING
HERE.
BUT EVEN FOLKS IN THE CHENEY
ORBIT ARE ALREADY LOOKING TO HER
NEXT STEPS, AND WE WILL, I'M
TOLD, GET A SENSE OF WHAT THAT
MAY BE IN A SPEECH SHE'S GIVING
HERE TONIGHT.
>> JEFF ZELENY FOR US THERE IN
WILSON, WYOMING, THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN SCOTT JENNINGS,
FORMER SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH, ALSO
CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR
CHARLIE DENT, A FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FROM
PENNSYLVANIA.
CONGRESSMAN, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
TODAY'S NOT THE DAY FOR POLLING
IN THE RACE.
WE'LL LET THE VOTERS VOTE AND
SEE WHAT THE OUTCOME IS.
BUT WHAT WILL YOU BE LOOKING FOR
BEYOND A SIMPLE WIN-LOSS IN THIS
RACE IN WYOMING?
>> WELL, LOOK, I MEAN,
EVERYBODY'S ANTICIPATING THAT
LIZ CHENEY'S GOING TO COME UP
SHORT TONIGHT, BUT I THINK,
REALLY, WHAT WE'RE ALL
ANTICIPATING HERE, SEE WHAT THE
MARGIN OF VICTORY IS, AND TWO,
WHAT WILL LIZ DO NEXT?
SHE IS CLEARLY -- SHE HAS
MOBILIZED A LOT OF REPUBLICANS.
LOOK, CLEARLY, TRUMP CONTROLS
THE PARTY, BUT I WOULD HAVE TO
GUESS THERE'S SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
20% TO 30% OF REPUBLICANS WHO
WANT A DIFFERENT DIRECTION, AND
LIZ IS REALLY SET HERSELF UP TO
BE THE LEADER OF THAT FACTION
WITHIN THE PARTY.
AND OF COURSE, MY HOPE IS THAT
FACTION WILL GROW OVER TIME TO
CHALLENGE THE TRUMP WING OF THE
PARTY.
SO, I REALLY THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT.
WHAT'S HER NEXT STEP?
WHAT DOES SHE DO NEXT?
DOES SHE RUN FOR PRESIDENT, OR
DOES SHE MOBILIZE LIKE ADAM
KINZINGER IS DOING AS WELL?
THEY'RE TRYING TO RALLY TROOPS
TO DEVELOP A BROADER COALITION
OF REPUBLICANS WHO WANT A NEW
DIRECTION.
>> SO, WE WON'T SHARE POLLING
TODAY, BUT INDULGE ME, SCOTT,
WHILE WE DO SHARE A LITTLE MATH.
LET'S LOOK AT THE DEMOGRAPHIC
BREAKDOWN OF WYOMING, AND JUST
EXPLAIN THE MATH HERE.
SO, TODAY, AS OF TODAY, HERE'S
WHO IS REGISTERED.
75% OF THE STATE IS REGISTERED
REPUBLICAN.
ONLY 13% OF THE STATE REGISTERED
DEMOCRAT.
12% IS INDEPENDENT OR OTHER.
HOWEVER, YOU KNOW THERE IS THIS
PHENOMENON WHERE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN REGISTERING AS REPUBLICAN
IN ORDER TO VOTE FOR LIZ CHENEY,
AND IF CHARLIE DENT'S MATH IS
RIGHT, THE 20% TO 30% OF THE
ORIGINAL REPUBLICANS WOULD VOTE
FOR LIZ CHENEY.
IS THERE A PATH HERE FOR HER?
>> I MEAN, IT'S HIGHLY UNLIKELY.
THERE ARE SO MANY LONG-TIME
REPUBLICANS IN WYOMING WHO
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP AND NOW SEE
MOST OF THESE RACES AS
NATIONALIZED, AND THAT'S REALLY
ONE OF THE THINGS SHE'S FACING.
I THINK SHE'S BEEN OBJECTIVELY
SPEAKING, A GOOD CONGRESSMAN FOR
WYOMING IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU DO
AS A CONGRESSMAN, BUT THESE
RACES HAVE BECOME SO
NATIONALIZED, AND IT'S TURN ON
HER KIND OF TAKING ON ONE
MISSION, AND THAT'S TO BE THE
LEADER OF THE OPPOSITION TO
DONALD TRUMP IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
MOST REPUBLICANS DON'T FEEL THE
WAY SHE DOES.
ERGO, WHERE SHE SITS TODAY.
SO, I DOUBT IT.
I'M LIKE CHARLIE, LOOKING AT THE
MARGIN TONIGHT TO SEE HOW THAT
MATH WORKS OUT.
I'M NOT ANTICIPATING HER
WINNING, BUT I'M CURIOUS ABOUT
HOW MANY DEMOCRATS CROSSED OVER.
I WORKED IN THE BUSH-CHENEY
WHITE HOUSE.
I FIND IT SHOCKING THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE ALL PRO-CHENEY.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER WHEN
THEY WERE TRYING TO THROW DICK
CHENEY IN THE WAR CRIMES JAIL.
IT'S STUNNING TO ME.
>> CONGRESSMAN, LET'S GO TO
ALASKA AND THIS SENATE RACE.
LISA MURKOWSKI, SHE'S THE ONLY
REPUBLICAN WHO VOTED TO CONVICT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AFTER HIS
IMPEACHMENT IN 2021.
SHE'S ON THE BALLOT.
WE KNOW THE RECORD FOR THOSE TEN
HOUSE REPUBLICANS.
SEVEN WILL NOT BE BACK.
TWO HAVE A SHOT AT IT, AND OF
COURSE, LIZ CHENEY IS THE TENTH.
YOU THINK THAT SENATOR MURKOWSKI
HAS A BETTER SHOT, A CLEARER
PATH TO COMING BACK IN 2023?
>> I ACTUALLY DO THINK SHE HAS A
VERY GOOD CHANCE OF COMING BACK.
SHE WILL ADVANCE TONIGHT IN
ALASKA WITH THIS RANKED CHOICE
VOTING SYSTEM.
SHE WILL ADVANCE.
SHE'S NOT GOING TO LOSE A
PRIMARY.
SHE WILL BE ON THE BALLOT IN THE
FALL.
NOW, WE HAVE TO SEE, YOU KNOW,
WHO ELSE BREAKS THROUGH HERE.
JUST TO HANDICAP WHAT NIGHT
HAPPEN IN THE FALL.
BUT I THINK SHE IS WELL
POSITIONED TO WIN AGAIN.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT SHE
DEFEATED A TEA PARTY FAVORITE
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
SHE LOST THE PRIMARY TO A GUY,
AND THEN TURNED AROUND AND RAN A
WRITE-IN CAMPAIGN AND DEFEATED
HIM IN THE GENERAL ELECTION.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, THAT TAKES A
LOT OF SKILL AND EFFORT, AND SO
I WOULD NOT UNDERESTIMATE HER
POLITICAL SKILLS.
SHE IS A -- SHE IS VERY -- SHE'S
VERY SHREWD, AND I WOULD EXPECT
HER TO RUN AN EFFECTIVE CAMPAIGN
IN THE FALL.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S GOING TO
GUARANTEE A WIN, BUT IF
ANYBODY'S GOING TO PULL IT OUT,
SHE WILL, AND SHE'S REALLY
BECOME A GOOD VOICE FOR MORE
CENTRIST POLITICS NOT ONLY IN
THE SENATE BUT WITHIN THE
COUNTRY AND CERTAINLY WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> SCOTT, QUICKLY, LET'S STAY IN
ALASKA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK SARAH PALIN'S
CHANCES ARE IN THIS HOUSE SEAT?
>> PRETTY GOOD.
I EXPECT HER TO DO QUITE WELL.
ALTHOUGH, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
SOME DETRACTORS OF HER BECAUSE
OF THE WAY SHE LEFT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THEN
ULTIMATELY LEFT ALASKA, BUT I
EXPECT SHE HAS A GOOD CHANCE.
MY ANTICIPATION IS THAT BOTH
MURKOWSKI AND PALIN ARE GOING TO
BE WELL POSITIONED AFTER
TONIGHT'S VOTING.
>> THIS IS A GENERAL ELECTION
RACE IN YOUR HOME STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
DID WE LOSE THE CONGRESSMAN?
>> HE HEARD WHAT YOU WERE GOING
TO ASK, AND HE WAS LIKE, NO,
THANK YOU.
>> OH, CONGRESSMAN.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> LET'S TAKE THIS.
>> IT'S STILL A GOOD QUESTION.
>> DO WE HAVE SCOTT WITH US?
>> I'M HERE, YEAH.
>> GOOD, SCOTT, LET ME COME TO
YOU WITH IT.
YOU'RE NOT A PENNSYLVANIAN, BUT
HETS HEAR YOU OUT.
THIS RACE BETWEEN LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR FEDDERMAN AND DR. OZ
WHERE FEDERMAN IS TROLLING
DR. OZ ON LINE.
WE SAW THE SNOOKI ELEMENT,
CONNECTING OZ TO NEW JERSEY, AND
THEN THERE'S THIS GROCERY STORE
TRIP THAT DR. OZ TOOK.
HERE'S A BIT.
>> I'M GROCERY SHOPPING AT
WEGNER'S, AND MY WIFE WANTS
VEGETABLES FOR CRUDITE.
>> THE GROCERY STORE CHAIN IS
CALLED WEGMAN'S.
HE SAID, WE CALL THAT A VEGGIE
TRAY.
HOW'S THIS RESONATE, DO YOU
THINK?
>> THIS VIDEO WAS MADE BACK IN
THE SPRING.
I'M NOT SURE WHY IT HAS NEW LIFE
IN AUGUST, BUT THIS IS THE CORE
ISSUE OF THIS RACE.
THE REPUBLICANS WANT TO MAKE IT
A NATIONAL RACE ABOUT INFLATION
AND JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO MAKE IT ABOUT DR. OZ,
SPECIFICALLY, ABOUT THE
ATTRIBUTES OF HIS PARTICULAR
CANDIDACY, SO MY SUSPICION IS
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE HIM
CONTINUE TO TRY TO TALK ABOUT
ANYTHING BUT THE NATIONAL
ISSUES.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO SEE OZ DO
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
FOR REPUBLICANS, NATIONALLY, THE
PATH TO 51 IN THE SENATE RUNS
THROUGH PENNSYLVANIA, SO THIS IS
A, IN MY OPINION, A MUST-WIN
RACE FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
SO I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
THEM ALL IN, AND BOTH PARTIES --
THIS IS LIKE GROUND ZERO FOR
SENATE CONTROL, IN MY OPINION.
>> CHARLIE, WE ONLY HAVE TEN
SECONDS.
DO YOU HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON
THIS?
>> YEAH, LOOK, THIS RACE IS
GOING TO BE VERY COMPETITIVE AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
WE HAVE TWO CANDIDATES, YOU
KNOW, THE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING
TO PAINT FEDDERMAN AS A BERNIE
SANDERS DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST,
ANTI-FRACKING, YOU KNOW, SOFT ON
CRIME, AND OF COURSE, FEDDERMAN
IS JUST GOING TO CONTINUE TO
POUND OZ ON HIS RESIDENCY ISSUE
AND THIS LITTLE CRUDITE
SITUATION DIDN'T HELP MATTERS.
I THOUGHT CRUDITE -- I THOUGHT
IT WAS CRUDE-ITE.
LIKE KRYPTONITE.
>> Y'ALL CALL IT A VEGGIE TRAY.
I GET IT.
>> VEGGIE TRAY.
THERE'S WEGMAN'S